Pokemon go has suffuse to my life I'm
the mother of two two fairly young
children 11ins and and seven almost and
they and you know they both took to it
so quickly and one of the features of
any service or game that swamps our
minds is that that is that feeling that
you've almost been waiting for it
sometimes I think about geriatric 1929
an early user of YouTube who said when
he first saw YouTube he was an RA had
been an RAF pilot he was at he's a
pensioner in England he he had lived in
a state of depression having lost his
wife remembering his heyday using radar
and sonar during the war and when
YouTube first appeared it was like where
have you been all my life this is what I
want to do I want to be able to
communicate with huge numbers of people
through the ether that doesn't appeal to
everyone but it appealed to many of us
who said when we saw youtube for the
first time the same thing happened with
Pokemon go you looked at it and we've
been on the brink of playing with what
augmented reality might be for a long
time looking at our phones looking at
maps and juxtaposing that with real life
and making and toggling between an
experience of looking at screens and
looking at real life and sometimes one
is more compelling and sometimes the
others more compelling Pokemon go in
juxtaposing it's little creatures on to
the world it's almost as though it is as
though we've been like almost training
for this in our dreams you know the the
onboarding for Pokemon go is so simple
there's so little to learn at the same
time I was learning that I was trying to
learn to play Magic the Gathering the
card game and I there was so much
friction in my learning it I knew that I
would be part of an elite cadre if I
learned it and it's very complicated in
esoteric but I just kept getting thrown
off the experience Pokemon go like other
great services on the internet you're in
before you know it and you're in with a
lot of people there's nothing I lead
about it and you know i i'm not sure i
think that it's a social good it
maybe and you never know when I argue
that the Internet is a work of art I
don't argue that it's like good for our
health I don't argue that's good for
society good from one of the parties or
another good for America good for
globalism I argue that it's art and art
leads us to places it changes us and
asks for us willing a willingness to be
changed and certainly kids and others
that are venturing out into the world
sometimes at night in strange parts of
the you know I was just in Newton
Massachusetts I saw a plaque I'd never
seen before the usual stories but when
people venture into that wide boundaries
outside of the narrow confines of you
know where you're kept in a safe spot
with other apps Angry Birds say you are
going to take risks and art asks us to
take risks literally asked to move us
from one place to the other exactly the
way Pokemon go has been moving us all
over the world wherever it's released or
wherever they're not trying to hack into
it all over the world to new places and
in that way I think it's a work of art
whether it's a net gain first
civilization remains to be seen
you